[Musique]
les etats-unis sont toujours à la pointe
du progrès cet étudiant américain qui
prépare une thèse sur les transports
miniature à réinventer la patinette pour
illustrer sa tête un repose-pied 4
roulettes un petit moteur voilà
peut-être comment sera équipé le piéton
de l'an 2000 c'est un peu encombrant
c'est simple et c'est économique que
deux lits pour 1000 km et voilà le
problème de la circulation résolu c'est
également un bon moyen pour ne pas user
ses chaussures voilà à quoi passe son
temps un étudiant américain on commence
à comprendre pourquoi certains savants
d'outre-atlantique s'inquiète du retard
que prennent les états unis dans la
conquête de l'espace interplanétaire
pendant ce temps notre étudiant es
content de lui il arrive le premier à
l'université avant tout c'est camara
[Musique]